desperate Democrats hoping to avert
disaster are now turning to the
president to bail them out in key
midterm races and deliver a powerful
closing argument oh we're not talking
about that guy
it's Barack Obama to the rescue the
dynamic duo are expected to get back
together and bail out Democrats in
Pennsylvania Obama is sure to be a
welcome sight because back in D.C Joe
Biden has all but checked out instead of
barnstorming the country with a flood of
midterm rallies Biden was getting his
updated covet booster shot and yammering
on about the pandemic he said was over
he's just no use to his party who were
struggling hard to deliver a coherent
message but top Democrat strategist
James Carville thinks his party can be
saved but there's a catch if we keep
this kind of NPR Foundation strategy of
identity left politics we're going to
lose I'm telling the same Elite Coastal
people forget everything we go we're
going to advertise and push the fact
that they want to throw people off of
Medicare and Social Security and they
want to shut the government down to do
it and that's how you win
you know um Dana it was I believe in
November of 2021 that James Carville
started talking about the wokeness and
said that they these people who are
awoke need to go to a woke detox center
um and nobody apparently listened to him
but it seems now that every you know we
get in the feeling that they're starting
to spin a little bit is it too late it
is it's very hard to turn around a
campaign in two weeks when you've spent
all of this money all of these ads all
of your focus has been on one thing
let's call it abortion and election
integrity and not the things that people
were talking about actually you could
chart the fives a blocks over the last
year and that's actually what people
were worried about and talking about the
economy and crime and the Border
actually so those three things and they
didn't they didn't do that so they made
strategic decisions that they're going
to have to live with uh so the pen the
Pennsylvania senate seat is interesting
to me for a couple reasons it was in
2010 Obama lost that seat uh he wasn't
able to save it that was after Obamacare
got passed and so now you know they're
trying to send him back there in order
to try to
see if they can pull it out I don't know
if that will work this time around the
Senate leadership fund has an ad out
right now that has the Bucks County law
enforcement officials saying directly to
the camera if you want your family to be
safe don't vote for John fetterman wow
and the so they're focused on the issues
and they didn't waste a whole bunch of
money in June and July they have the
money to spend here I understand that
some of the money that's coming out of
New Hampshire in order to be able to
really helped push Oz Over the Top in
Pennsylvania so tonight the the debate
is important but still I think all the
work that the Republicans have done up
to this point to narrow this Gap to
where it is today sends Biden to
Pennsylvania but I don't know much how
how much that helps fetterman I believe
that it just showcases fetterman's
vulnerabilities you know Jesse uh
fetterman this is the first time that
he's appearing with Biden the fundraiser
they had the other day but what's what's
interesting about Pennsylvania is I was
looking at what is most important to
pennsylvanians they said inflation in
the economy second thing was abortion
third thing was Voting Rights crime
wasn't even in the top three in
Pennsylvania how does that vote for
memadize
well the economy's still number one so
that's has been his main message and he
has touched on crime and he's visited
Philly and you got to put the work in to
get out the black vote in Philly and
Pence and Pittsburgh and that's why
Barack Obama's there to turn out the
black vote in those two cities I don't
think there's a lot of black passion for
Joe Biden I don't see a lot of black
passion for for John fetterman he chases
blacks with shotguns and he hasn't
campaigned for months Oz is actually
going to these places and getting his
name out there and Oz has great name
recognition within the black community
so it's going to be tied and I don't
think barack's there at the right time
where's Barack Obama been for the last
year he's late he's like the guy you
know when you're cleaning up the kitchen
after a big dinner party after 45
minutes Barack Obama comes how can I
help yeah I know yeah okay where have
you been for the last 45 minutes so this
isn't going to do it but Barack Obama
for legacy reasons needs Joe to keep the
Senate because once these investigations
start into the Biden crime family it's
going to come out that the Biden family
was taking Chinese cash during his time
his VP right under Barack Obama's nose
that's not going to look good for the
former president you know Geraldo you
left when Jesse talked about fetterman
chasing the black with a shotgun yes but
that is true and uh fetterman uh you
know was reported on doing that I mean
it was not it was when he was mayor of
Braddock yeah sets a record straight he
campaigned against violent crime and
under his watch for five years there was
no murders at all in that heavily uh
black what's that got to do with it
fetterman worked it and he brought down
crime listen
to answer the question about his chasing
a black man with a gun I think that he
has explained it to the extent that he
can people buy his explanations
I I don't think there's any question but
that there was a gun and a black guy he
was wrong
he may have been wrong that's your
assessment now let me just say
climate change and and transgenderism
gets you gets you elected class
president not Senator or Governor so the
Democrats are finally seeing the the
light of day government's first job and
I I understand this latest poll out of
Pennsylvania uh doesn't have crime up
the top I sense it is the best the most
important job of government is to keep
people safe the second most important
role of government is to make people
feel safe it's the sense of feeling
security as much as it is the fact of
being safe and nothing has a New York
state for instance to shift one state up
nothing has helped zeldin more than that
video of the black guy pushing the uh
the kid with the knapsack onto the
tracks and it's played on the loop on
the local news we play it on uh uh you
know kids City kids nightmare is that
exactly being pushed onto the tracks of
the subway so I think that the Democrats
have their work cut out for them and
that it's all that crime and plus it's
the price of the gallon of gas I think
that that's very important and you know
Greg tomorrow we'll be talking about the
Federalist debate but the the Curious
Thing is that that Geraldo just said
something about you know it's important
that people feel secure you know that
that just reminded me of the perception
thing with mayor Adams you know it's a
perception of crime it's feeling secure
the truth is that people are not secure
people are not safe yeah I think uh I
mean the senate race in Pennsylvania is
going to be close I'd say it's neck and
something that looks like a neck
but I do think Joe and Obama together
it's a perfect pair they're the yin and
yang Joe's poll numbers you know or gone
to the dogs and Obama eats dogs call
back to back 12 years I had to do that I
get the importance I don't get it it's
okay
dogs we can't forget that and I'm never
gonna let America forget that so
everybody keeps talking about the
Democrats it's really important they
have a message and it's kind of sad to
that you can't naturally be something
because you're so bad that you have to
come up with a message the problem with
the Democrats isn't their message is
that their parties apart has fallen
apart Geraldo is right they the Dems
have to admit to themselves that
oppression theology uh non-binary gender
bathrooms uh uh uh
indoctrination education that stuff
doesn't work right you get this is the
wake-up call you have only so much shelf
space in your head and in that shelf
space are the adult issues crime economy
border what happened is they pushed it
all out and they replaced it with this
this kind of attention-seeking Twitter
Twitter HOT issues the stuff about
gender the stuff about race changing the
names of schools these are not things
that people sit around and talk about at
their quote kitchen table so what
they're learning now is that they forgot
about America and nothing there's
nothing that Obama can do for them
there's nothing that Joe can do for them
but they got to do it for themselves
because the fact is
you have like this is their Q Anon
they're this kind of like upset this
identity Pollock obsession is their q
and on they have to clean house no
matter what we say we're they're not
going to listen to us that's why they
didn't listen to us about the five if
they listen to us the five for two years
there wouldn't be a crime problem so
it's up to them to listen to themselves
listen to the carvilles they're the ones
and not only that listen to the New York
Times it says it's time to switch uh
switch tax and uh start talking about
inflation which the Dems exacerbated
yeah stop eating dogs yeah when they
talk they're willing to even if they
talked about it they're not willing to
change policies though yes
on inflation they keep saying that the
Republicans are going to make it worse
and everyone else in the world has it
just as bad as we do that's like that's
not talking about Advantage actually
changed the police I think the most
important person in the uh the the
failure of the democratic party is
George Floyd I think that once he was
murdered the uh the country went crazy
with defund the police and everything
else so the Democrats led the charge but
very very unrealistic not the country
though just just part of the factory
they're not even going to have black
lives matter the organization not the
movement